Prime Minister John Key made a trip down  south this week for the official opening  of the new Invercargill Airport terminal  the 13 million dollar upgrade has been a  year and a half in the making and as a  stark contrast on the city's original  terminal which while serving the city  well since its opening in 1964 was  quickly becoming outdated Key said the  new terminal was a reflection of how  well the region was growing it's a  wonderful - it's a it's a absolutely  fantastic statement of how well and  McCardle is doing and how well Southland  is doing so increasingly you've got  chose to come here they want to see this  fantastic part of the world they want to  go down an experienced Bluff or  experience things that you've got here  the great scenery you've got and all the  things that are on display the packed  functions or dignitaries from around  Southland come together to celebrate the  city's latest venture